pour voir si le nouveau système de
numérotation shadoks tenait debout nous
vous avions poser un petit problème
voyons quelle est la solution
il y aura un autre problème à la fin de
l'émission voilà le nombre shadoks
traduit en français beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs avaient trouvé mais pas
mal de shadocks aussi il faut avouer et
oui le système du professeur shadow
comarch cet ex bannis les shadoks
maintenant avec motifs grisé par le
succès le professeur produits sont
magistrales et s'attaque aujourd'hui à
la réforme de la joie mais aussi
géométrie shadoks reposer sur un
postulat assez bizarre qu'ils disaient
la ligne droite est le plus long chemin
d'un point à un autre et vous
conviendrez que pour les voyages
interstellaires ça risquait de poser des
difficultés mais grâce à shadow co tout
cela ait changé
ecoutons-le warbasse première dame le
clou définition le point est la plus
courte distance possible entre deux
premières applications étant données de
l'ign quelconque trouver l'endroit où
elle se coupe
supposons qu'elle se rend compte en zoé
me par exemple si l'on est ainsi d'après
notre définition la ligne zoho me serais
un point et serait plus courte que le
point but or ce n'est pas le cas donc
les lignes se rencontrent en bus d'où
théorème deux lignes qui se rencontrent
se rencontrent toujours au même endroit
propriétés remarquables tout ligne
prises hors d'un point ne passe pas par
ce point ou alors si ali passe c'est
vraiment par hasard
deuxièmement les points parallèle on dit
qu'un point est parallèle à deux autres
points lorsque ce point est en
convenablement disposer si on le déplace
d'un côté ou de l'autre
il est plus parallèle d'où théorème la
condition suffisante pourquoi points
restent bien parallèles à deux autres
points et qu'il reste là où il est et
qu'il ne bouge pas en deuxième partie la
leaf on appelle ligne de premier choix
lénine qui ne passe que par des points
parallèle on appelle dean chad o'quinn
encombrante les lignes qui passe
plusieurs fois par un même point haut
par plusieurs on appelle ligne de
deuxième catégorie des lignes qui arrive
sur un point qui s'arrête on appelle
ligne deux dernières catégories aux
petites lignes les lignes qui ne passe
que par un seul point
[Musique]
et maintenant un petit exercice de
mathématiques shadow si un chat de que
pour moi le long d'une ligne de premier
choix parcours dit shadoks mettre à
l'heure combien mettra-t-il de temps
pour parcourir 11 shadoks m
la réponse dans notre prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]